when we talk about Health Data we think
security because it's sensitive data
when data circulates inside a computer
there's no such thing as zero risk
the only answer to this is to have
regulation that's efficient allows fluid
access to data and is extremely secure
so in practice how does the Health Data
Hub work there are several systems in
place
[Music]
no point in the Health Data data
pipeline process are we allowed to
access directly identifying data
[Music]
the platforms
within the platform that we've built
with the machines in France to meet
European standards the data is encrypted
uh
this means that it's like encrypted
passwords on the Internet it's the same
thing but obviously with extremely high
levels of encryption
we open secure bubbles for each research
project that operates on our platform
these bubbles are totally sealed from
each other totally independent and the
researchers only have access to the
pseudonymous data that they need
obviously there's no way to take the
data out of this bubble and there's a
criminal ban on trying to re-identify
people
[Music]